should a writer aim for a certain amount
of rejections per year and if they're
not getting those rejections and that
means they're probably not getting out
there enough that a interesting way to
look at it or maybe I'm too negative
here that's entirely possible
I you know I don't know if there is such
a thing as a certain number of
rejections you know whether you are
setting the bar for something you know
for failure or not I think you know
instead I would turn it around and say
okay I think once a week set a goal for
doing at least one piece of marketing or
two pieces of marketing I think that's a
better way of looking at it than saying
okay I've had 10 I've reached the
threshold of 10 rejections this month so
I'm not gonna do anything now I mean
that to me is more negative so I would I
would say okay let's do this in in a
week let's let's look why don't I look
up you know five different places that I
can send out letters or that I can send
emails to or why don't I look up ten
different resources for competent screen
screen writing competitions or something
doing something like that I think is
much more productive because you never
know when one of those are going to come
but to just say well okay if I did this
many rejections then that means I it
because who knows if you didn't do that
next one two fine pieces of marketing
marketing just means making the effort
to get out there whether it's posting
something you know that that you feel is
you know like there are places that you
can post your your story ideas you know
and your your synopses and then if
someone's interested they will then
contact you and then you can let them
you know look at your script and they
can you can get your script read so you
can post your projects you can be you
can you know to me it's not just posting
a project it's also like
making plans to enter competition making
plans to send out you know to go to a
conference or something those are
positive things that are moving in the
direction and you have to invest in
yourself I understand that sometimes
people go yeah but I cost money to enter
a competition
or yeah it costs money to go to a
conference well you know if you if you
if you're really if you're really
serious about it you have to make the
investment in yourself somehow and so
maybe you have to be a little bit more
frugal about things okay maybe I can
only spend ten dollars or something or
twenty dollars or whatever it is a week
that I'm going to do the socks out of
way for it but whatever it is you make
those plans I mean that's that's just it
I mean I know that I I have clients who
have done who did it for years before
something happened for them but now
things are working for them or they
really feel like they can't stop and
they're really doing some some really
good work and it takes a lot of time you
can't just expect it to happen overnight
it because it doesn't and that that
certainly that survey I took of all
those professional writers proves that
it doesn't work overnight it took that
one writer who did 12 speak 12 scripts
before he got an agent I think he said
he he wrote those 12 scripts over 15
years oh wow and you were sounds like
you were very surprised to hear that
numbers I was and you I was this is this
is a guy who was a top writer you know
yeah you would think that oh well you
know something must have happened and
right away something you know that that
it would continue and continue but and
also like the the one guy I told you
about who on her first script got
somebody to read it and buy it but it
took her five years and had four more
scripts before she got somebody to
option her second one and it never got
made unfortunately they optioned it at a
studio and then a new set of people came
in and you know and they didn't want to
continue with that particular script but
you never know I mean those that's how
how this
businesses you know I'm hearing that a
lot of regime change and and how should
someone stay current because that is
difficult when a new group of people who
don't know you and maybe they had sort
of a relationship with you come in how
do you ingratiate yourself to a new
regime well it's hard to personally do
that but to be aware of it what you need
to do is like and especially if you have
a writers group if you guys together get
a subscription you know to the reporter
or the brighter whatever one you want
you choose and you guys share that share
the subscription and you know in fact
there's there's people who have writers
group where people take turns doing it
so that once a month they they rattle
off ok here's what here's what I read
you know and here's and here's the
latest news up that that I've gotten and
then that the next person next month
another person does it so that everybody
is well-read but reports everything back
to everyone and I think that's a nice
way of being able to do it's networking
but it's also getting out really good
solid information hey so-and-so is no
longer at the head of this this
production company hired a new story
editor this pert it's information that
that is valuable to the whole group and
that's that's how you keep current
naturally if you have an agent or
manager they should already know these
things but don't count and this is
another I think a mistake that a lot of
writers make they feel that if they have
an agent or a manager they don't need to
do anything right and one of my friends
one of my best friends actually has won
an Oscar and she tells me that a lot of
her a lot of things that happened it's
not because she has an agent or a
manager it's because she made the effort
to go out and talk to people and to find
out what was going on and you know she's
kept up her even though she lives out of
town she doesn't live in Los Angeles but
she keeps up with email and you know
phone calls and she is in touch with a
lot of the producers and production
people that she used to do business with
when she was living down here and she
said it's been the most valuable lesson
that she's learned is to keep those
contacts and send Christmas cards or to
give him a call every once in a while
and you'd be surprised one of the things
is that she happened to write a movie
for somebody who was at a television
star of a television show
and I'm not gonna mention the name of it
or anything but that actress her star
really rose and what happened is my
friend happened to see her at at a
Writers Guild event and went up to her
and talked to her and the woman looked
at her and she goes oh my god you're the
one who wrote the script for that movie
is the week that helped my career shoot
up and it was like she she remembered
her name because of that I think you
know and so she says you know if you get
a chance you know if you if you're
writing something you think I might be
good for it please let me take a look at
it and sure enough a year later and my
friend since that said it to her and so
they took a look at it there I don't
know if it's anything has come of it yet
but I do know that that it's something
that is on their mind so it's on their
radar and they might be doing it there's
some other material that she's doing
that other commitments she has so you
never know
you